d'amour merci de nous accueillir dans
votre grotte c'est mon ange voici que
tout se passe avec mes amis depuis 40
ans parce que vous êtes un passionné de
jeux de société je pense là j'adore lire
les règles pour moi lire des règles ça
me ça me grande ça me barre j'essaie de
comprendre des fois c'est
fumer je réussis au bout de trois quatre
lectures plus les vidéos règles assez
comprendre pour voir bien les expliquer
à Magan qui vient passer toujours moi
qui fait ça vous aimez les règles mais
pourtant tous vos personnages n'aiment
pas les règles et dans la vie je ne suis
aucune règle c'est difficile pour moi de
suivre des règles dans la vie mais dans
les jeux suite by the book mais
effectivement dans mes rôles parce que
c'est suit les règles
arrête
non non
je peux dévoiler punch mais quand même
là
tu aurais fait quoi toi
mais oui il le défendu le défendu bon
mais en 40 ans de carrière avez-vous
déjà vu ça un tel succès parce que vous
devez vous faire arrêter dans la rue
constamment je me fais des je me faisais
déjà arrêté parce que ça fait 40 ans je
fais ça comme tu dis puis que j'ai eu
bon déjà mascotte j'ai eu plein plein
plein
bon c'est autre chose c'est vraiment
autre chose de ça 99.9% du temps c'est
toujours des très bons commentaires et
ce commentaire que je sais que vous avez
des cheveux trop longs puis vous avez la
peau propre mais
[Rires]
là
est-ce que Norman l'amour est un
bourreau de travail parce qu'après ça
vous aurez pu prendre des vacances bien
mérité mais là vous embarquez au TNM
Théâtre du Nouveau Monde avec le rêveur
dans son bain
alors oui c'est beaucoup de travail
beaucoup de travail oui mais pour moi je
n'ai pas l'impression de ce personnage
je me suis ouvrage non plus mais j'adore
ce que je fais ce qui me sauve comme je
dis souvent c'est les siestes moi je
peux faire du siège par jour de 15-20
minutes puis ça ça me régénère
entièrement puis le tagueur
et enfant justement amour avec votre
conjoint parce qu'elles Montreuil il
était proche vous reprenez du nez de
compte
c'est comment jouer avec sa conjoint sur
scène
on s'est rencontré sur les sorcières de
Salem il y a le 25 ans on a fait le
blues de la métropoles aussi une dizaine
d'années aussi puis on rejoint ensemble
puis je suis très heureux de ça parce
qu'on part en tournée puis des fois
quand tu seras faire une tournée l'autre
est à maison c'est moins drôle là tout
ce qui va nous arriver c'est qu'il faut
faire garder les chiens peu importe on
est très content d'être ensemble
et votre fille Marguerite qui est aussi
comédienne comédienne comment papa Vita
7 ans
mais c'est vrai moi je pense que le tout
ce qu'il faut pour le faire alors le
talent
cette faculté d'adaptation c'est ce que
ça prend dans ce métier là soit mais
après ça pour avoir les rôles quoi que
ce soit juste avoir une bonne attitude
de envers les autres dans ta vie aussi
[Musique]
vous aimez ça je pense les rôles qui
sont plus grands que nature
puis oui j'aime ça puis j'aime surtout
leur trouver leur vulnérabilité
là-dedans aussi fait que c'est ça que
j'aime beaucoup c'est goloque qui
prennent la place maintenant
c'est là que les gens aiment
c'est sûr que les gens aiment voir de
voir que oui tu peux être fort dans la
vie mais il y a toujours cette Hummer là
qui existe en arrière tu sais Pascal
s'inspire justement il est très violent
ça devient
bien quand même c'est dancing
si tu me poses des questions ou même
excuse-moi faut que les choses roulent
il faut que les choses
normalement merci beaucoup pour cette
revue